tu vas un petit peu prendre d'hélium et
tu va nous chanter le refrain de sol
j'adore cette chanson pied je la connais
par coeur
celui qui n'a jamais été seul est au
moins une fois dans sa vie
tél
la nuit parce que ça altère tellement la
voix et la corde vocale est bon de s'y
montre la réaction mais on arrive à
s'échapper d'une note quand même ça
marche
hyper bien surtout en fait plus on a une
fois tu vois plus ça marche ça naît ça
fait rien n'est tombé dans les jeunes
[Rires]
donnez votre ballon oui et donnez votre
ballon on garde beaucoup de faire une
deuxième est ce que tu peux nous faire
alors ce duo avec céline dion a osé que
céline dion nous regarde je suppose une
sphère sous le vent c'est parti mettez
le passage de céline dion et prendra
c'est un bel agrément comme si là ça
commence à mayronnes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
be back
il va tomber malade merci pour les aînés
le moment faire une dernière me faire
une dernière
c'est une des chansons préférées de
chaussée de raymond c'est la rivière de
notre enfance avec michel sardou et de e
books bout c'est une de vos balades hors
je t'adore sa réflexion il adore les
rivières qui coulent
il adore l'enfance oui ce n'est pas que
c'est ce à quoi est-ce que vous avez
regardé on va leur faire regarder on va
la remettre
vous allez il a chanté un petit peu et
garou à la chante avec vous pour vous
faire un petit kiff d'accord il ya d
imaginer la s'imagine si dans cette
émission en direct on flingue la voix du
gaou normalement mes frères la bannière
ou comme si tu fais engueuler veux je te
baylet je m'engage à te trouver une
émission sous symbian